an entire cs go roster has been dropped
by its team
and banned from fpl after elise
exposed racist and homophobic behavior
by its members now they've hit back
and claimed this whole thing has been
blown out of proportion
so who said what how bad is it
and are these bands justified
[Music]
all right just before we get into all
this madness i'm gonna remind you guys
to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss any stories like this
in the future all right so all of this
started last week when someone on
twitter
by the name of sin xoxo shared
screenshots from
one of snap's pub games now a former
player on depth esports cs go team the
screenshots showed some pretty toxic
behavior from snaps take a look for
yourselves
and after that tweet snap was suspended
from playing
for a week by his team now that could
have been the end of the story
but team liquids elige tweeted out right
after
saying that the depth esports members
were some of the most
racist and toxic people he'd ever played
with in cs matchmaking he followed that
up with a pay spin of screenshots to
illustrate his point and
they certainly did allegedly these are
the depth members and
others using the n-word among other
slurs on a private discord
it just goes on and on and
on so after elisha's tweet people
started to call for
action to be taken against the players a
product manager from
faceit who works on the fpl immediately
tweeted
saying that the players were banned with
no foreseeable readmission
shortly after that depth esports
released their entire csgo
roster stating that they take the
integrity of the organization
very seriously before wishing the
players well going forward
and with that it was over the initial
exposure
the spotlight from elige and the
organization response
happen in less than a day about 15 hours
to be precise
you'd be forgiven for thinking that's
where the story ends but the now
teamless depth members then shared their
side of the story
csgo content creator counternature
interviewed them
and they claimed the bands only happened
because
elige weighed in they banned me for one
week because it's not that big of a deal
and then it leaves sweets
oh my god it has so much attention oh
i'm gonna ban all them permanently
i'll face it everyone even even people
that haven't even like
typed in pugs they didn't even go and
check those records
and they said that they banned for
excessive use of uh
whatever for for the community so even
though they weren't sure
why they got dropped they said elige and
other pro players were solely to blame
well yeah these pros
like they're just they're just idiots
when they think they have like like a
little effect on what happens with their
i don't know
they caused most of this they would have
literally swept under the rug and
everything would have been fine
they alone caused this so
and they didn't just clap back early
they really went in on him yeah he's
being like idolized for that even though
he's like literally just like
just come back for doing that he just
ruined like four people's careers for no
reason
literally for no reason and when it
comes to what was said in discord and in
games
they don't deny those things but they
felt like it was okay because it was
between
friends we don't just go around calling
people that like think about how you act
with your closest friends or closest
family
it's like that man some of the [ __ ] you
would like say to your closest friends
or family would be offensive towards
other people
if you were saying it to them but you're
saying it to them because it's a joke
between
between friends now despite how absurd
this interview felt at times
of course elijah's tweet turned this
from one player being suspended to an
entire roster being dropped but
isn't there behavior what's to blame
here depth esports ceo
jonathan levity blamed their roster
choice on it being their first
entry into counter-strike so they didn't
have the connections at the time to
fully get a grasp of the players
personalities
snaff the player whose toxic behavior
had a spotlight put on it at the start
of this
all ended up sharing an apology a few
days later
in it he said i want to apologize for
anybody that was offended by the way me
or my friends acted in private
if you looked at the screenshots you
would see that i used homophobic insults
and my friends use racial slurs
i just want to say that my friends and i
had no bad intentions
saying these things and no ill will as
we were not saying these things directly
towards people to offend or attack them
so yeah it certainly seems like his tone
had changed little
since that interview with counter nature
taking responsibility is one thing but
it's the damage already done here on
february 16th
esea released a statement stating that
even though the behavior didn't take
place
in one of their leagues they would not
tolerate the behavior because the
ex-depth members
did play in the highest of their leagues
they issued them all a one-year ban from
esea tournaments for unsportsmanlike
behavior
unfortunately this isn't the first time
we've covered a story
just like this on this show if you
remember last year we reported on twitch
streamer jenna
having hundreds of racist anti-semitic
and transphobic discord messages leaked
if you've been paying attention to
twitch or reddit lately
you've probably heard about this jenna
news the popular just chatting streamer
first was accused of sexual misconduct
by viewers and then had
hundreds of discord messages leaked that
allegedly showed her using racist
sexist anti-semitic and transphobic
language in this discord era these
things feel like they're always going to
become
public at some point whether you're a
pro player
an amateur player or a big streamer so
what do you think did the depth esports
players
get what they deserve or was the
punishment too harsh
let me know in the comments
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages